legs is a very soft metal and it's
easily molded and to all sorts of shapes
this is a pot I'm not sure what it's
from I got it from the old lab that was
being closed down so it was probably
made for holding a strong acid because
lead is very unreactive you can see
rather nicely here the white and color
of lead oxide because it's oxidized over
the years and this is the white material
that was used for paints that this white
lead paint that people use the oxide of
lead had one rather unfortunate
consequence that it reacts with sulfur
in the air and in Victorian times when
people burnt coal that produced a lot of
sulfur and the sulfur reacted with the
LED to give a black color which made the
white paint eventually turned gray and
if you waited long enough black and this
effect was exploited by one of my former
colleagues here professor Leslie crumby
who during the war was working for the
British Admiralty in their research labs
on the camouflaging of submarines now if
you want your submarine not to be seen
when it's well away from the coast it
needs to be white because if you have a
white submarine it doesn't show up
against the sky but if you're trying to
slip into the coast at night and not be
seen you need the submarine to be black
so Leslie came up with the idea of
painting the submarine with lead oxide
and when it was going near the coast
some sailors went out onto the outside
of the ship and sloshed over a solution
of sulfide in seawater and the paint
turned black
and so you could then go into the coast
drop your agent do whatever secret
things he wanted to do and then when you
went away from the coast
they sloshed hydrogen peroxide with
seawater which turned the sulphide into
sulfate and so lead sulfate is wait so
your submarine went wait again so you
could change the color of your submarine
to suit what you were doing in the
military operation and nobody would see
you and that was a real thing that
happened yes that was real thing
I don't know how widely it was used but
they actually tried it out and it worked
so they just needed to take the
chemicals and they could add the
seawater to make the solution to put on
the submarine the other very important
property of lead is that because the
lead atom is heavy it is very good at
stopping nuke radioactive particles
particularly alpha particles which a
helium nuclei those are the nucleus of
the helium atom or beta particles which
are electrons so it should find as if we
put this in the way it should stop
counting almost immediately so let's
save the books
go straight back down to background we
take away kicks back up again and so
people who are working with radioactive
samples used to use and still use bricks
made out of lead so here are two of the
bricks you can see this is a small one
and this one is rather thinner the
problem is that if you have start
building these bricks into the wall
there's always a chance that some of the
when you have two bits together there
may be a slight gap between the two
bricks and some of the radioactive
particles may go between them so to
avoid this the bricks are made with
grooves in it and pointed part here so
that when you put them together there's
absolutely no way that anything can go
through because you can't have a direct
line through it now the trouble is of
course you can't see anything through it
so if you have an experiment where you
want to handle radioactive material
inside the container and manipulate it
you can't make the whole container of
lead because you can't see what's going
on inside and so for that people have
developed LED glass of which this is a
sample and it is immensely heavy but
this is glass and which there's really
quite a large amount of lead that's put
in it and some of the fancy crystals
that your grandmother's all your
ancestors might have had had a bit of
lead in the glass this is got really
quite a high proportion of lead in the
glass which is probably why the glass is
yellow rather than the white colour that
you normally have with glass but windows
like this can be used for handling
really quite radioactive materials
behind them so the colors rather nice
isn't it but it's um it's very heavy
so
well lead has had a very long history it
was one of the first metals to be widely
used the the Romans used this for
drinking materials they also led acetate
that's compound of lead and vinegar is
meant to taste sweet and the Romans
added this to their wine to make it
sweeter the fact that it was really very
poisonous and caused possibly even cause
madness was not really widely recognized
in fact some people have suggested that
part of the collapse of the Roman Empire
was due to too much laid lead was very
widely used in the UK for water pipes
because it's easy to manufacture and to
join together it tends not to being very
dangerous in terms of drinking water
because it gets a coating on the surface
so you do not get much laid in the water
though if you do have a house with lead
pipes and it is usually advisable to
change them it's again it was used very
widely from the 1920s up till the late
70s or 80s as an additive for petrol in
the old days when petrol engines were
first M introduced when you came to a
hill and put down the accelerate of your
car the engine started misfiring so
called pinking and the whole thing shook
so it was really quite difficult to
drive up hills but then it was
discovered that you could put in a
compound so called tetraethyl lead which
was really very poisonous but the guy
who discovered it washed his hands in
public at a press conference saying look
it's so safe despite the fact that there
were people dying in his factory so it
was very widely adopted and so it was
only in quite recent times that it was
realised how much lead was being blown
out in
the atmosphere and car exhausts and so
it's now we have almost everywhere we
have led lead-free petrol as a result of
people realising the poisonous of lead